Hey get out of here. HEY! HEY! You piece of shit.
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Slime Rancher.Now in this episode
I'm gonna get a lot more shit done.
I need a lot more money number one, and I need to get this wall higher before they steal all of my chickens.
They eat the rooster. I'm gonna be pissed, but as it stands now
They're already making babies, so no. Hey!
You weren't rebelling before why rebelling now. Maybe I just got to feed these guys you can stop being so goddamn greedy
Yes, I get it it it. You don't want it to be fair. Oh no, all right.
Just hurry up and get over there anyway. I'll be right back. I'm gonna get some shit done.
NO GET OUT OF THERE
you sack of shit, you pieces of Garbo
I'm gonna fire you off into the edge of the oblivion if you keep fucking up like this
You know what there's too many of you did you guys reproduce or something NO, no you do not
You do not you do not you. Do not why are you going so much higher?
No, no, no II and in fact, how do you get out? You're never getting back in that's what we do
That's how we do that is the justice that we serve here
And I will not tolerate it anymore you guys are being fired off into oblivion. I'm sorry (nooo)
It's just waited. Goodbye farewell have fun in the ocean bastards, okay. Goodbye (evil mark)
Why big smiles they go up to their oblivion? I think they're hungry
Which is not exactly my problem. NO no no well
Maybe you don't know you don't know you don't know you don't know I don't know how you guys get
Fucking assholes you fucking assholes. You NO
Oh my God
You sign some shit you do not belong in my farm if you're gonna be such an assholes
You fucking I don't care if you're hungry
It doesn't look like I care
oah my Goad
You ain't ever HOW?
How are you assholes getting out of this you know what this is bullshit
How the frick fuck are you how I don't understand. How you guys got in there
What in the shit happened?
(mark contemplating life)
Okay, anyway
We're gonna pretend like that isn't reality and we're just gonna have a good old time here while I fire these fuckers off into beep
Oh, you want to survive now. Oh?
No, I tried to save you and now you're dead okay. I can get more of you
You're replaceable fuck man all my chickens at least they didn't get my roosters
But it's just one hand - these two roosters thought they even got my stony ones
(oh no not the stones)
goad damn it? Oh, they're fightin? No no their fighitin up a storm, so that ill be right back
I gotta deal with this bullshit. What is this?
Treasure pot is locked okay. I didn't even know what a treasure pod was I don't know why it's locked. Oh
What you are you? OHHHHH!?
Well that was horrifying oh Heyyyy
You jumped big good, okay? Well, this is just sad. I'm gonna get out of here
yee yee
Hmm alrighty, then wow those guys are unhappy. Why are they out in the middle of the day that doesn't make any sense?
(OH SHIT GOLD SIME)
goooold
g-gooooold oh come on go- awwww
I don't know what to do for that. Do I feed it. Do I have to feed I probably have to fee-
I've just blasted. God damn it the gold mother humper. All right
Let me go in here and see if I can remember if I can get these guys to calm down ello buddays
Grunt oh Cube oh cube
Yoo-hoo
Okay, all right
Hey, oh, whoa, whoa? Whoa? Whoa? I got food free buddy. Oh
They're so happy now whoa. Hi friend boink. Okay? Sorry about that
They're happier now angry no no no no no no how what the hell no eat that
(slime poops while mark watches)
eat that, AGH not you jeez explosions are awfully squary another secret to hiding from me
Where's this go? Oh it's locked
No, I wish oh
maybe maybe that key might be from the pink one and then the other one is from the
Cat one and then I can figure out which one to go to later
(no just no)
Mmm secret Secrets, we're getting to the bottom of this, but I'm not back yet. So everybody go away ow ow ow
Stop it boink boink boink. Oh. Oh, it was just one more HEAIGH
Okay, I got a key
Whoa, I got a key boink yay
its rainin nerps whatever this currency is is it in nerps?
I think it's nerps not 100% sure, but I think it might be nerps all right whatever anyway, Gonna
Take my fruit and run let me see if this key
Let me see if it goes to this ashh shuld probably drop my plorts back I'm gonna dump my plorts back
I'm not back yet everybody. Go away. I'm not here. You didn't see nothing. I'm an enigma markiplier doesn't exist markiplier never was
There's no channel here. What are you talking about Zall an illusion I'm a paid actor
(holy shit that's deep)
Hmm
Okay, that's a good amount of money. Maybe you can get an upgrade now for myself
water tank
Store fresh water jet pack or module the water tank. That's how it can water
All of these are good, but I like the jet pack I do want the jet pack
I lika me a jet pack and then maybe
With the end of grade high wall 350 okay, so I'm close getting high walls for these bad boys you go on tomorrow. Hen
Hen there you go, okay? Now. I'm officially back. Let's see if this cave actually has
The key oh no if I have the key to this caves door
(wut?)
Hey
whoa
Everybody who's so happy about that? I left the artifact that was so nice
So what's going on in here? Oh?
Indigo quarry all the remains of all the remains of a mining project right they quickly went bust okay I?
Was always happiest when I was told by my lonesome places like this old quality really suited me nice and quiet and mostly empty
So I figured that life on the far far range would suit me just as well and well wouldn't you just know it I come?
All this way and the first person I see huh well she changed how I saw things why it wasn't good anymore
I'd like to laugh ha ha ha ha. Oh, that's so nice
That's real nice ok so what do I do about this quarry? Is there like some special poopie here? Oh?
Oh, whew we got oh, we got an assortment. Whoo. We got a whole plethora
Ryan pink boom Largo here have one of these
Give me your poop give me your boom poop. Oh, that's nice boom poop. Okay? I'm gonna take that don't boom me
Eat that oh shit. You're a little concerned to be all right
Wow, all right that guy
eat that
eat it oh
vegi and meat
Give give give me your plorts. I want em boom ah shit (no I'm a virgin)
Wow ow, okay. Fine. I get it. I get it I get it I get it hey. Oh God. I'm gonna Die shit shit
just eateateateateateat
I just want your plooorts you
Just try to scoop up the remains of whatever plorts are here Oh boy
yee yee oh, this is a bad time to come over here. Oh, this is not ideal. Not ideal. They are all dying very quickly
Oh should I go deeper? Oh, then I saved him oh boy
Ah well can't save nobody no more. Oh boy
Okay, I just sacrifice the rock Lord. I'm sorry. I saw whole line oh
Hey
you're in here eh oh, oh, that's
Nice, treasure pods are locked. I don't know where I went. I ran away from the
dah tars what's going on here? Oh?
Wow, oh, that's cool
Neato reed oh man this place is so much bigger than I thought it was
They've expanded in a big way around all of this island, and there's just like a lot more to see oh
What are you are you radiation slimes?
Are you wanting if you want to eat? These hens? Is that what you want?
What do you eat rad veggies? I don't have veggies on me. Oh you are rad slimes
You're so rad. Give me those uh shit. Nope. Oh
No, don't know ah get a uf a me. Oh, God damn it. I don't
(Godzilla sounds)
that didn't work out well, but okay don't eat. Don't eat. Don't eat. NOAH don't eat that plort don't eat that plort!
did I get it? Oh, God, I got radiation on me
yeesh
Can deadly here puddle plort?
wats a puddle plort
There's more slimes in there. Oh, that's cool. Oh
That's really cool. Oh
Hello, more. Plot. I used to come here when I needed a good soak. It's a great way to clear your head
Sometimes I'd catch a puddle slime blushing, and I could never tell if it was because I was in my bathing suit oh
no, ha ha ah
( ‾ʖ̫‾)
Flirting with slimes that's weird and what have we got here? Whoa?
Oh my God look at that are those flowers oh
There's so many of you where am I oh, I'm in the deepest part of this cave
Ah that's neat. Oh, that's neato rito. See where this goes and I go anymore, but I don't know oh. Oh, okay, ooh
What are you oh?
Nothing apparently there ash flowers are first and ask before I could get to him. Oh that one's so pretty oh
That one's like a special different version of it know that it's a crystal slime
Whoa, okay there?
That's awesome
That's so cool. There's another treasure pot over here, but I don't know how to open them. Oh god. Oh, oh. Oh, okay?
I'm out of here
I see that other text there, but I'll come get it later when I'm actually need to be here gathering up some slimes and
Actually building pens for me. I could try to pick a rad slime home, but I don't think it's Gonna be useful you upgrade available
whoo
Okay, so I get better sprinting. That's not bad. Oh
the hen mother load
Yeah, but I'm full up right you hands. I'll come back for you. You stay good okay, but that's cool
So that's a whole nother segment with even more slimes that could possibly be for who knows how many uses hey big buddy
I'll come back for you later. I don't have enough veggies right now, but I'll come back all you be worried. Where am I going?
oh, I'm still oh, I didn't even realize I was still in the crystal land a welp that bad just
Gonna pretend like nothing's happening, and ignore that I don't have nothin I can do about it
So we're really worried you remember me. I still
Still exploit. Oh you can you can still to the wolf. It's not exploit apparently are you oh God?
What's with these treasure pots?
Do you guys know what the treasure pods are about because there's treasure pods here
And I want to know I want to open them
I want to open them somehow, but I don't know that whatever I'll get to it later
Figure it out, okay here. We go. Let's load it up. Oh, God
Brockport's, oh the rock. Oh no those are crystal. Oh, okay, brad Forks are good all the boom ports are good
Oh, I got so much steel, okay
I can finally start housing you assholes again, but maybe I should you spend my money on a better pen
I know I can get I can get a good one as long as I got high Walls
Should be fine either way high walls probably good
and then an auto feeder would be good, but I don't have the money for that right now, so
All I got right now are that so anyway? I'm gonna. I'll be back. I'm not done yet. I'm not done yet
I got more to do and maybe I should take a little nap inu. Let's see Beatrix is four
Okay, whatever I go sleep till morning get a good night's sleep. I sleep with a slime plushie
Oh, that's so self-serving all right, so we got high walls in that pen
We might as well put something good in that one like a rad if I get a radiation one in there
That's going to be good for me whew maybe I should try to get the volcano ports. Oh boom slime boom baby
Boom baby okay, so if I get enough boom slimes, yes
oh
Yeah, but always always always you surprised me with that when you're thorny, bitch right, but if I get more of these boom boys
That could spell good news for me and bad news for all of my competitor slime ranchers
Cuz I'm going to make more money. Go man put them out of business. That's how this works, right?
It's another one of those guys. I don't know what to do about the Golden moon
I wish I knew what to do about the golden one. I wish oh God freak you. Go away. I don't like you
How about I give him a fruit of some sort and okay, Oka?
(guess that will work)
Where'd he go ies hes gone
Do you do about the Golden ones?
I think the only thing you could do is feed him right or maybe I'm not good enough to be able to
Farm him up okay. How did I get back to the Volcano area? I think was over here?
(MARK FUCKING WAIT!)
Maybe well, no, I didn't I oh
(GOD DAMNIT MARK!)
God damn it. I forgot my jet pack wasn't
recharged
Frick a dick well that sucked ass well that was all pointless because now all my boom slimes are gone great fucking great
On you, I want all of you. Well. I want the crystal plort ohhhh, okay got it. I'm gonna give these crystal slimes
crystal slimes crystal slimes my babies whew you're in me, okay. Come here. Don't be shy oh
some plorts? yes, yes ow
No, yes. Oh you were about to poop well oops my bead
They got crystal plorts now
Good oh jesus, oh
Seems like a dangerous place to be but just want to get me some ports
I just want to get me some plorts ooh boy want that slime okay? He's buried in there amongst friends
Now not you eaten up all the valuable plorts
Incredibly valuable plorts oh bam jeez things are blammin, okay, you come here you blam you're good, okay?
Whoa Chris OH MY GOD THIS IS DEATH THIS IS DEATH NO DONT GET KNOCKED OUT OH MY GOD!
(panicking mark)
I'm out of here freak. I'm out. I'm outie. I'm out. I'm calling I'm calling it. I'm calling it quits
I'm calling it quits while I'm ahead. I'm gonna. Take these very valuable things back home with me
before I ded
No, don't go do well while I'm down here. I get those grab more
Things I don't know if I want all of these crystal bad boys inside of this (or in me)
Oh hearing the vision
I once came here to collect crystals for a little project - mine was trapped here for nearly two days when those curious
Crystals limes came rolling my way and started firing all those dangerous odd
I thought I was gonna kick the bucket the crystals were for a wind chime, and that Thoris still has it hanging from the porch
Was it uh?
How romantic you almost died?
Love is he a little dizzy hey, that's enough Crystal slime stops sprinting please
Recharge please I'm not going to come with my pants down again. All right, so we got some money
We got a lot of valuables, and we got even better
We have Crystal slime
So I'm pretty sure these crystal slimes are going to be worth a whole heck in lot
To me because just their ports are like I think 40 apiece
They're they're a big value in and the boom slimes are good
But you know at least the crystal ones don't explode whenever that kill near home
So these might be better to keep a line
And then I can just I can just focus on sustaining these bad boys, and then I don't have to worry about anything else
Oh, hey
No, no, okay?
So the question is I don't know if crystal slimes need a special container because the crystal slimes were in a cave system
so it may be that the crystals lives need the cave area to thrive in so
I get enough money to be able to open that up. I have enough
I may not have enough because I'm pretty sure
Maybe it's the foss for ones or maybe the crystal ones need like the solar net or the solar
protector because that might be a -
Because they think this is going to be like a thousand odds forever okay, so I can't do that
But what I can do. Maybe is create a solar
protection like Solar Shield because if I had to imagine
It's probably the solar shield that's gonna help these guys right
(no mark just no)
Yeah
Always happy. Oh look at them alright
see you guys are there so just imagine that you guys get a regular sustainable supply of carrots and
You're super happy and you give me more crystals?
Give me those crystals. Yes, oh
My God, that's that's gilly that's scrry. Is that you having fun. That is your version of fun
You guys look like you're having so much fun. I'm just going to leave these here for you
I don't have an auto feeder right now, but that's the best. I can do who plort tell you below
Jeezum I'm bad alrighty then
You guys stay in there you're having a good time. I'm not going to put all of them in there just yet
I'm gonna see if these guys
These guys okay here cuz I got meat for them. I got me oh we got a lots of meat for you guys
You guys want some boom-boom meat?
Yeah, you do leave these guys in there with you to stop play nice. I suppose are you boom boom boys?
Boom boom boys and boom boom girls blink blink blink and a boink boink boink boink boink OKAY
We're doing a lot better than we did at the beginning of this episode
That's for goddamn sure and if I get an upgrade I can get the dash boots. Oh
More efficient hell, yeah, and then power core would be good ah yeah, more energy. That's definitely good
Oh, and then the tank booster all getting next so I can carry more stuff back and forth
Oh, they're so happy look how happy
They are I could put the rest of the slimes in there
But I don't want to go overboard or someone's gonna die so that is it for this episode
Thank you everybody so much for watching I love
Just like the pleasantness of this game. It's just really really like eyes it nice. I gotta give you lead I don't
Sell these it's so um nah cancelled or refunded. I'll try to feed them. I guess you guys don't eat
Yeah, none of these guys eat fruit, so I probably got to replace that with more veggies
But we'll get that we'll cross that bridge when we get to it, so either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think down in the comments below
That guy's trying to make an escape with his boom powers not today and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye
Coleby Kaman did subtitles
look at that slime dance
other people did too not just me.
bye